as things heat up between kanye west and
julia fox a source tells et that his ex
kim kardashian quote isn't bothered
it's a different experience for sure on
tuesday night the rapper and the uncut
gem star were snapped out in los angeles
together yep that's kanye in a dark
hoodie jeans and boots and julia wearing
a similar ensemble but instead she's
rocking a leather jacket and neon heels
an eyewitness tells et the pair enjoyed
dinner at hollywood hot spot craigs
before ending their night at a nearby
hotel and get this amid the fan frenzy
kanye even stopped to sign autographs as
for how kanye's estranged wife kim
kardashian feels about all of it well a
source tells e.t that the reality star
wants to move on from the grammy winner
so she isn't bothered by his new romance
quote kim is happy if kanye is happy and
she is glad that he's putting his energy
into someone else romantically at the
end of the day life is about being happy
of course the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder has been spending more and more
time with saturday night live star pete
davidson i love that um that energy in
my life but a source recently told et
that kanye is still trying to get kim's
attention quote kanye is trying to make
kim jealous by being very public with
julia he is trying to make a point i'm
just extremely happy can you tell by my
face
but the source did add that kanye and
julia are having a good time hanging out
and getting to know each other better
quote julia thinks kanye is really cool
and is also just enjoying the ride while
it lasts i'm thankful before their
hollywood date night kanye and the 31
year old actress previously spent an
evening in new york city together taking
in dinner and a show which in true
over-the-top kanye west fashion turned
into a full-on photo shoot shared by
interview magazine i mean it was just
fun just do something for my heart an
eyewitness told et that the two dined at
italian eatery carbone and left the
restaurant just before midnight as for
julia she told the mag that the whole
night which ended with a hotel suite
full of clothes felt like a quote real
cinderella moment quote i was so
surprised like who does things like this
on a second date or any date everything
with us has been so organic i don't know
where things are headed but if this is
any indication of the future i'm loving
the ride it was really surreal and while
a source recently told et that the data
four is trying to move on from his ex
who recently returned from a whirlwind
trip to the bahamas with pete previous
sources told et that kanye was trying to
repair his marriage to kim in fact in
december the famous rapper purchased a
4.5 million dollar home on the same
street as his ex and their four kids e.t
source explained that kanye wanted to
buy the house because he thinks it will
be easier to co-parent with kim if they
live close to each other and kim agrees
but when it comes to rekindling things
with kanye kim isn't exactly on the same
page last month the skim's founder filed
ducks to emphasize her desire to quote
terminate their marital status as for
julia turns out she's a kardashian fan i
love that back in december she opened up
about the famous family's reality show
keeping up with the kardashians coming
to an end on her podcast forbidden
fruits i'm gonna miss keeping up i've
been watching keeping up since it first
came out in like 2007 when like watching
it was embarrassing me and julia are
like die hard kardashian fans like we
watched season one episode one as it
aired it was like very embarrassing to
me i wanted them to be my family yeah